Speaker 1: Donald Trump's lawyers are now
turning on each other. It is getting very ugly
and predictably so. Law and crime has a very good
piece. Trump's lawyers turning against each other.
Legal experts react to the report that Christina
Bobb said she was told to sign the alleged false
statement about Mar a Lago ducking documents. This
is really interesting what's going on. I mean,
of course, it's a train wreck. It's a car crash
in every way. But it's also interesting. Legal
Twitter was abuzz over reports that one of
former President Trump's attorneys recently
spoke with federal prosecutors about various
details regarding allegedly classified documents
discovered at Mar a Lago, according to
NBC News, citing three sources familiar
with the matter. Attorney Christina Bobb, a
one time talking head on one American news,
named two other Trump attorneys involved with the
case during a recent talk with the U.S. Department
of Justice as law and Crime previously reported,
Bobb signed a letter in June of this year
saying that Trump had returned all documents
subject to a may grand jury subpoena. We know
that wasn't true. That letter claimed Trump no
longer had any documents identified as classified
at his Florida State. The statement Bob signed,
however, was allegedly authored by Trump attorney
Evan Corcoran, according to the New York Times.
The report is that she now is saying, I was told
to sign it. I didn't believe that it was true. I
am another one of these victims here. And very,
very quickly, it is not only Trump attorneys
getting attorneys, but it is Trump attorneys
pointing the finger at other attorneys. Now, there
is a legitimate legal question. How solid is your
defense if you say, I knew it was false, but they
told me to sign it. Different legal opinions have
come down on this. Some say this is actually
not a crime that Kristina Bobb committed. I'm
relaying what someone else told me. As long
as she is telling the truth about that and
there is evidence that this was her idea or her
thought to sign and put together this document,
that someone told her to it, to do it. You can
make the case that she is not committed any crime.
That's one legal opinion. The other legal opinion
is she is confessing that she knew that what she
was being told is false. You know, there's
this legal idea of the lawyers are following
what their clients tell them they believe. And
it is not really up to the lawyer to determine
whether they are being told something that's true
or false. But if she is admitting she knew that it
was false and still signed off on it. I've also
read legal opinions that say now she could also
be in legal jeopardy. What we know is Christina
Bobb was hired by Trump for her ability to be a
talking head on television, and that is often how
Donald Trump hires his lawyers. We will have to
see where this all falls. But it is an extremely
risky, from a career standpoint, decision to
agree to be Donald Trump's attorney. So Trump's
attorneys now pointing fingers at each other.
And I predict in the next month it's going to get
very, very interesting where this falls. Let me
know what you expect. Find me on Twitter at David
Pakman. And we will be back right after this.